are you sure you don't want some help
from patrick swayze
this is much more romantic in my head
welcome to night in night out the show
where we compare a home-cooked tasty
recipe to
a night out at a fancy restaurant today
we're going on not one but two dates and
then at the end we're each going to pick
which one
was the better date today's episode is
pizza so ariel and i are gonna get
cooking
so we're making veggie pizza right well
i was gonna make a meat pizza
so we're going houses i like spinach
basil maybe
yes
i'm italian half italian italian sausage
italian blend
but is it made from imported organic
italian tomatoes when eating bacon
no it's not italian prosciutto is one of
my favorite things to put on a pizza
it's a fancy meat
it's nine dollars
a little cake wine i know that's olive
oil here's your olives oh yeah
easy they have special flour for pizza
well it's
it just says pizza on the all-purpose
flour oh i know
we'll just get that a little bit of a
yeast active dry
that's the only type of what i just like
looking at the options
oh no i'm pretty sure this is it all
right we'll see you in the kitchen
we're not just making a stuffed crust
pizza we're making an
entirely stuffed pizza
you're just going right into this yeast
prepper okay yeah
we got some yeasty water it smells kind
of yeasty
here we go making dough
why are you moving it away from me oh
yeah
oh that's good what do you want to do
for the next hour
now i can play with pizza is it big
yeah look at this a little flower there
now we're going to separate it into
quarters you ever do the lebron ariel
[Music]
roll tide baby pizza facials have
many beneficial properties is that right
did i put the wrong spray in uh you know
it's done now
and now we add the cheese
go go
i have just the thing you do nice joy
thank you okay it's a cocktail strainer
but today it's gonna make
a fun outer crust it looks kind of
like a ball sack you can't beat them
scrotum
a little olive oil salt and pepper and
we bake it all right
let's put this bad boy in the oven
okay okay what if we made a tiny little
pizza
a bean make a bean pizza
no food today bean you're getting
pizza he's just going straight for the
tournament he just wants to turn
he's like i don't know about all this
other stuff you guys oh oh yeah
how do you like your sauce do you like
it heavy life like a kind of
light it's all about the ratios
[Music]
get over the line
okay now we can put it back in finish it
off i got it
[Music]
oh my gosh we nailed it i can't wait to
cut into it and there'd be like cheese
everywhere
all right you ready i'm ready do the
honors
that was very dangerous you're not that
bad at cutting things
[Music]
middle cheese there's like a whole base
layer of cheese here
this is nice here oh my god this is so
exciting
[Music]
really good not pepperoni popping a
little spice to it my kalamata olive or
excellent idea mm-hmm i love that this
is my pizza and that's your pizza
because this has all of my favorite
things on it it just has some like
[ __ ] that i sometimes eat because
i'm forced to
what does it make you think of next we
think of like hahahahaha i'm like
running through a field but instead of
wheat it's all just cheese
making the pizza was almost as fun as
this
is delicious well it's going to be tough
to top this
with anything other than cheese and
pepperoni
that was a quality dad's okay i'm
getting prepared are you ready
for the fancy pizza i am ready for fancy
pizza
let's get fancy
my house it's like good but your
outfit's like no
sarah please no your outfit is like oh
you're so sweet
we are now on our way to a fancy future
now
[Laughter]
so we are now on our way to the fancy
pizza restaurant
it's called pizana and guess what
it's italian
[Music]
i'm daniel odie we are a pizzano in
brentwood los angeles and this
is my first pizzeria in this beautiful
city you're
a hundred percent italian i am 100
neapolitan because i was born in naples
so we have tomato sauce instead of blood
[Music]
my family owns a bakery in casserta
close to naples and
i was like 13 12 and i start to clean
their oven and then the end of the night
i stretch a couple of pizzas and then
that's how i learn
take one end play like
ah little bunny though pizza started
it's perfect my grandfather started a
beautiful mother though it's called
krishito and i refresh it every
day the yeast strain has existed for 60
days it's a starter so
that's actually what makes this dough
special so we're going to have a base
with our beautiful fertilizer our
reduction of san marzano which is a
sauce that we cook for six to twelve
hours we're gonna sprinkle a little bit
of parmigiano reggiano
and it's ready to go in the oven this is
the oven that you imported from italy
yeah i put the first stone on this pizza
oven wow so
cornerstone yeah right yeah the material
have come from the mount vesuvius so
this vulcan stone that they preserve for
the eruption that the vesuvius had long
time ago
it gives you the perfect baking process
because
a vulcan stone takes the heat like a
nobody business
it's just a consistent crispiness yeah
because december is always the same
my pizza is cooked a little bit longer
but i want you guys to taste that we use
a wood burning oven when you bite to the
crust you know that crunch
i like that sound oh yeah
all right basil crumb and that's the
idea of my new margarita
let's make a brassica which is
ferdinante broccolini
which we cook in the wood burning oven
and then pickled calabrian
shallots and sicilian pesto which is a
pesto made out of sun dried tomato
walnuts and
parmesan a woven pizza a lot of bacon
jam underneath some
cherry tomato prosciutto at the end
we're going to crack an egg on them oh
yeah that's sexy
wow that we have already had pizza today
i i'm ready for my pizza i can't wait
to crack this egg
oh oh my goodness
now you're just playing with your food i
am just playing with the egg now are you
ready yeah all right
where are you gonna margarita cheers
cheers
oh that's good that's so good
in every bite you get a little bit of
tomato a little bit of basil
and a lot of cheese it's very well
balanced it's very look at this
look at the scoring on the bottom can
you hear that crispy
do you hear that crispy crispy crust i
do seriously one of the best crusts i've
ever had
and the dough is like a little sweet
little sour
it's just good bread i'll do that one
you do this one yes
okay ariel is going to try the brassica
pizza with the broccolinis
and i will be trying the wovo wow ready
whoa whoa whoa that's it
i'm getting myself a handmade brick oven
from naples
putting it in my kitchen there are
things on this table
that you can't buy in a grocery store
you can't even buy in america
it's like my tongue is just laying on a
velvet carpet doing snow angels
it's that care in your craft that i
think makes
us a good good good pizza did we have
garen our craft no
we had fun we always i don't know if we
hit craftsmanship i feel like we should
turn these cameras off so that i can
properly stuff my face
yeah can we show the camera's off
ariel it's time to pick a winner what
was the better date the night in or the
night out
night out okay
but why our pizza didn't even compare
no we can't make that pizza at our house
we don't have
a brick wood burning oven that burns at
700 degrees
30 years of experience this is why you
go out for the most amazing pizza
even if they are costing 18 per pie
i would pay 30 pizza the night in was so
fun we
had this like gorgeous stuffed cheesy
crust
and watching it rise watching arrives
was so fun but the night out was also
like the craftsmanship
and the flavor combinations were amazing
i think
my winner is
the night out chef is more italian than
i am
is italian far we come out leave us a
comment which one would you choose the
night in or night out and if you decide
to make our pizza recipe please post
some photos
and if you have a neapolitan pizza oven
in your house we want to know where you
live
because we will come visit you well
happy date night sweetie happy date
night
love you love you why don't you do it
we're on our way
to run our way here
it's perfect though because it's our
ball set oh yes